dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly shown IFA here let's
try to assess the workflow of this piece
of work in the shortest possible form
the input is images of cells and the
output of the algorithm is a decision
that tells us which one of these are
cancer cells as the pipeline of the
entire experiment is quite elaborate
will confine ourselves to discuss the
deep learning related step at the
variant techniques prior to this one
involved adding chemicals to blood
samples the problem is that these
techniques were not so reliable and that
they also destroyed the cells so it was
not possible to check the samples later
as the title of the paper says it is a
label-free technique therefore it can
recognize cancer cells without any
intrusive changes to the samples the
analysis happens by simply looking at
them to even have a chance at saying
anything about these cells domain
experts have designed a number of
features that help us making an educated
decision
for instance they like to look at
refractive indices that tell us how much
light slows down when passing through
cells light absorption and scattering
properties are also recognized by the
algorithm morphological features are
also quite important as they describe
the shape of the cells and they are
among the most useful features for the
detection procedure so the input is an
image then come the high level features
and the neural networks help locating
the cancer cells by learning the
relation of exactly what values for
these high level features lead to cancer
cells the proposed technique is
significantly more accurate and
consistent in the detection than
previous techniques it is of utmost
importance that we are able to do
something like this on a mass scale
because the probability of curing cancer
depends greatly on which phase we can
identify it one of the most important
factors is early detection and this is
exactly how deep learning can aid us to
demonstrate how important early
detection is have a look at this chart
of the ovarian cancer survival rates as
a function of how early the detection
takes place I think the numbers speak
for themselves but let's bluntly state
the obvious it
from almost surely surviving to almost
surely dying by the way they were using
l2 regularization to prevent overfitting
in the network we have talked about what
each of these terms mean in a previous
episode I have put a link for that in
the description box 95% success rate
with a throughput of millions of cells
per second Wow Bravo a real two-minute
paper style head tip for the authors of
the paper it is really amazing to see
different people from so many areas
working together to defeat this terrible
disease engineers create instruments to
be able to analyze blood samples doctors
choose the most important features and
computer scientists try to find out the
relation between the features and
illnesses great strides have been made
in the last few years and I am super
happy to see that even if you are not a
doctor and you haven't studied medicine
you can still help in this process
that's quite amazing a big shout-out to
cram who has been watching too many
papers since the very first episodes and
his presence has always been ample with
insightful comments thanks for being
around and also thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time